the killing of Tyree Nichols an unarmed
black man pulled over in a regular
traffic stop by five police officers in
Memphis Tennessee has reignited the
perennial debate over race and policing
now this case is different from the
other prominent officer-involved
killings that have preceded it George
Floyd Michael Brown Brianna Taylor in
that Not only was the deceased person
black but all of the officers involved
in his death were also black and it all
took place in Memphis a city that is 65
percent black
nevertheless former Congressman Democrat
monder Jones warns people not to be
distracted by those facts if you think
Jones wrote the Memphis police officers
had to be white in order to exhibit
anti-blackness you need to take that AP
African-American studies course Ron
DeSantis just banned
yes
everyone involved was black
but they were still motivated by
anti-blackness which is just another
woke Buzz term meaning white supremacy
as viral Libs have rushed to point out
on social media
I got a message today for some white
people if we have white people
listening paying attention I wouldn't
mind if you would do this with me we rub
our chests we find our heartbeat
and we say we did this
we did this
white supremacy did this
I'm talking about
Tyree Nichols
the police didn't do this
the Memphis Police Department didn't do
this
white supremacy did this
the cops have been arrested they're
presumed innocent until proven guilty
even though the video evidence that we
have is pretty damning but by the
standard of the left viral nobodies and
prominent politicians alike even if the
cops are convicted it wasn't really the
cop's fault
according to many on the left the
responsibility for Tyree Nichols is
killing and really for all the evils in
the world lies with white people and
their alleged system of white supremacy
even when the white people are nowhere
in sight the video of that white liberal
lady saying that even though
even though all the cops involved in the
killing of Tyree nickels are black even
though Memphis is a black City even
though white people were nowhere to be
seen she says beat your chest beat your
chest white people this is our fault
this shows you a point that I've made
for years now which is that racism white
supremacy all these terms are just just
uh synonyms in our modern culture for
evil it's so it's always got to be white
people's fault the the
ultimate sin is racism and and by racism
specifically
racism from white people white supremacy
white nationalism whatever you want to
call it and what what she is doing is
expressing a weird modern lib version of
the true and traditional doctrine of
original sin
she's even beating her breast in in
Christianity what we do is we beat our
breasts and we say
Maxima culpa
the the understanding of original sin is
that we in our sins have killed Christ
we have slain Christ because Christ is
Incarnate to die for mankind to redeem
Mankind from his sins because we all
sinned in Adam when Adam first took that
bite of the apple and lost his paradise
and sin and death pervaded the world so
we in a very real sense are responsible
for Killing Jesus you might say well we
weren't walking around first century
Palestine doesn't matter we because of
our fallen Humanity which is not just
some weird thing that we're imagining it
is an observable fact this is a fallen
world and we all sin so that part
totally observable obviously true uh the
understanding is that we are born with
that and so we we carry a real fault and
we continue to sin in our thoughts and
in our words and what we do and what we
fail to do now the Liberals intuiting
this fact of human nature
reject all of the all of the stuff that
goes with it the Liberals reject that
God exists often they reject that we
need a savior who comes outside of us
they reject uh they reject everything
about our traditional culture and the
religion that animates our traditional
culture but they realize that these
facts still exist and so they just have
to transmute them into some weird new
leftist religion and so what they do is
they transmute that into a literal
beating of the chest over white
supremacy which is not the cause of it
very often you will hear people say the
original sin in America is slavery or at
a broader level the original sin of
America is racism
that isn't true
all that stuff is there's plenty of bad
stuff that happens in America and other
places around the world
but the original sin of America is
original sin and when you try to try to
translate that into some weird modern
religion where you get rid of God and
you get rid of all the all the stuff
that undergirds it you end up sounding
like wackos like that liberal lady on
Tick Tock and like Monday Jones
white supremacy did not cause this
killing we we don't really know
The crucial fact here
which is what happened before the video
came on
there's video footage now body cam
footage
dash cam footage has been released
officers to Darius Bean
Demetrius Haley Emmett Martin the third
Desmond Mills Jr and Justin Smith
have all been charged with two counts of
official misconduct uh one count of
official oppression second-degree murder
obviously the biggest one there
aggravated assault act in concert and
two counts of aggravated kidnapping
the video footage looks very very bad
there is there is one question that
remains which is why did they pull this
guy over they say that they pulled him
over for reckless driving
the head of police in Memphis says that
we don't have evidence of that yet so we
don't know really the cameras kind of
click on as this is happening
so you don't really see the earliest
parts of this encounter then uh Tyree
Nichols resists arrest and runs away and
then they get him and they basically
just beat this guy to death he doesn't
die on the scene they don't get a
medical attention he dies later at the
hospital it's really damning stuff it's
hard to imagine these guys are going to
get off the hook for it but
in this country people are innocent
until proven guilty so we'll see if
anything comes out on trial as to why
they pulled him over in the first place
why this escalated so quickly one theory
that is going around right now
a very Politically Incorrect theory is
that these cops were hired with lowered
standards so this is a theory a law
enforcement official Karen parmar says
according to a source within the Memphis
PD the five officers charged were not
hired through the usual PD hiring
process city leaders felt the existing
process was too strict and kept certain
people from getting jobs at the
department city leaders began their own
hiring process and then pushed new hires
into the agency bypassing the testing
procedures in place at the department
we know that this sort of thing happens
there's a big lawsuit about this in New
Haven some years ago because first
responder exams uh allegedly there
weren't enough people of certain
demographics there wasn't enough
diversity in the department and so they
lowered the standards
um it happens whether it happened here
it remains to be seen but it is being
reported by multiple outlets and this
this is
one of the weaknesses with democracy
this is one of the weaknesses that the
founding fathers wrote about framers
wrote about that political thinkers have
have recognized throughout history which
is that if a regime becomes too
Democratic you have a leveling and so
it's not that everybody is raised up to
the highest levels of Excellence but
rather that everybody becomes sort of
handicapped like Kurt Vonnegut writes
about in Harrison Bergeron or like we
see today just a lowering of Standards
okay not enough people that we want to
get into certain schools or not get are
getting into certain schools so we're
just going to get rid of the SAT we're
going to get rid of the ACT we're going
to lower the entry exams to become a cop
or to become a firefighter we're uh not
enough women are in the military we want
more women in the military let's lower
the physical requirements to get into
the military and so it's just it becomes
a lowering to the lowest common
denominator and and you you see this in
the writing of our founding fathers
that's why they did not give us a
democracy that's why they write so
disparagingly about democracy uh it's
why they didn't even give us
quite a republic or just a
representative democracy in that the
American form of government really
includes aspects of all three types of
government there are three types of
government
monarchy aristocracy and democracy and
according to the ancient writer polybius
those are the three good versions of
that government it's not that only one
of those is good the other two are
terrible all three can be good but they
have a corrupted version too the
corruption of monarchy is tyranny the
corruption of aristocracy is oligarchy
the corruption of democracy is Mob Rule
and and uh he he views this as a kind of
cycle of regimes that is constantly
going to evolve so what the American
Founders and framers tried to do is
establish a regime that includes aspects
of all of them you have a monarchical
element in the strong executive and the
president you have an aristocratic
element it's certainly in the Senate and
elsewhere in the government a
representation for the landed classes
especially when there were more
stringent voting requirements and it was
just a more of an aristocratic kind of a
society and then obviously a very strong
Democratic representation too it is that
what happened here we don't know it's
going to go to trial but regardless even
even in this case where the facts are so
clear was there a white person in sight
no it doesn't look like it very very few
if any nevertheless you are going to see
the popular press
just
absurdly
try to blame this on the usual old
culprit white supremacy the reason
they're going to do that is because that
phrase is simply a byword for evil in
the Fallen nature of man
in modern America
now
this is not to let the cops off the hook
here
conservatives are generally strong
Defenders of cops I am a strong defender
of cops I'm a specially a strong
defender of cops in Memphis I don't know
how many of you have ever been to
Memphis Memphis is a very dangerous
place Memphis is one of two places in
this country that I have ever been
jumped or very nearly jumped the other
was on the Jersey Shore where I Used to
Vacation a lot as a kid the other one
was in Memphis I was in Memphis for one
night back in I want to say this is
I was probably 10 years ago more than
that probably at this point and
I I was uh stopping off in Memphis with
a buddy of mine we went to Beale Street
which is the main drag had some drinks
had a couple coca-colas listen to some
music then we were walking back we were
probably two blocks off of Beale Street
uh it kind of stood out like a sore
thumb smoking cigars I was probably
wearing some silly colored polo shirt
but we're walking we see some guy it
looked like he was either breaking into
a car or he looked like he was up to no
good and we hear hey fellas I said I
don't want to talk to this guy we walk
in the other direction he starts walking
he goes fellas fellas he starts walking
after us we start walking faster he
starts walking faster we run he starts
running after us finally and we had
cigars so we didn't want to just go
inside but we see a hotel so we get in
front of the hotel there's obviously a
huge camera right there we're right in
front of the opening and closing doors
and this guy stops running right outside
the the frame of the camera he can see
the camera too he's a little bit further
out he goes hey guys you come you want
to come over here
said that no there's all
can you can you give me some money
said no there's oh it goes can you pray
for me
we said yes
yes we can pray for you absolutely
and I kid you not he goes can you pray
for me over here he's still trying so
desperately hey come on over here so I
can jump you and steal your money this
was two blocks off Mill Street the main
part of Memphis okay so I don't think
Memphis is going to be served by taking
cops off the streets I think probably
Memphis needs many more cops on the
streets
but you still need training you still
need high standards and you still need
just as served I mean you can't you
can't allow just roving gangs of
untrained cops to go around terrorizing
people we'll see what happens I'm
probably the the only commentator in all
of America who who thinks that we should
wait to see what comes out at trial
before totally forming our opinions but
facts certainly don't look good today is
music Monday the rest of the show
continues now Mr Davies and the
producing team
has some really profound music for me to
analyze because you know I am a cultural
Maven I am this the hip-hop pippity pop
kind of music man over here you don't
want to miss it become a member and use
code knowleskin to wlas at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you over there
[Music]
foreign